they're not coming for us are they sure
movie begins with some out of nowhere
flashback explosions that are supposed
to mean something I guess but really
only served the boner of Michael Bay a
guy putting flowers on a grave in the
rain cliche I'm thinking maybe they
should have adjusted the lighting or
just picked the day where it's not so
fucking sunny outside to film with rain
machine this gravestone plays the
pronoun game it didn't matter if Tony
Scott directed it or Michael Bay did Don
Simpson and Jerry Bruckheimer made sure
all of their movies looked 100% the same
back in the mid 90s I'm having trouble
distinguishing this movie from Crimson
Tide the Navy's conveniently blatant
signage is both blatant and convenient
also when they were making the sign were
they worried that they wouldn't have
enough room after typing naval but
instead of just starting over with a new
sign they just typed weapons a little
smaller then realize they had enough
room after all so decided to go back to
the original font size for the word
depot this side of the naval base isn't
guarded even though there's a visible
watchtower that is inexplicably much
shorter when they get to the top of the
hill are doing something besides
guarding when a group of people show up
with the plan to break in cliche these
Marines shoot off loud grappling hook
arrow guns that hit the fence with no
one noticing it sure these aren't lethal
weapons they're using but this dude just
crashed through a window and fell out of
a 30-foot tower so if he's okay it's
only because they got lucky movie
reduces the u.s. Navy two Bond villain
henchman we got 30 minutes to those
starts were off and that we now know
they were shooting the other military
personnel with darts so they are still
morally on the up and up even though
they're there to steal chemical weapons
to threaten San Francisco why would just
anyone on the base have access to this
room but now sedated soldiers were just
guarding it and they don't need access
if these weapons are as dangerous as
we're about to find out they are then
only a few people should have access to
them right right jesus H Christ how many
of these skin burning chemical weapon
missiles that we probably will never use
do we need and why the are they
protected only by a padlock and not
another fucking keycard train soldiers
get sloppy just so you can see the
devastating effects oh they're stealing
uh-oh that's a Beatles album right there
1964 James Bond will not be happy
because on the beetle maniac and second
these sound better he's gonna play the
DS sound better card then he should know
that he could get one that's not a first
u.s. mono pressing for about the same
price as a CD the detergent could be
sarin gas at the end they have to do
this every time the Turgeon comes
through the airport Sarah
gbes that is correct it's excellent that
marvin is being trained so he has to
tell the trainee things that are
valuable for us the viewers to know
isn't don't play with the potentially
deadly objects inside a crate even
though they seem unassuming one of the
first things you've learned at chemical
weapons specialist school I want to know
much extra time it took them to rig the
baby dolls eyes to open when the weapon
is triggered because that was definitely
not time wasted also whoever designed
this went to the Batman bill an
institute of weapons design I have some
more bad news the FBI didn't spend the
extra money to get the suits that can
withstand corrosive materials even
though this is a chemical weapons lab
there's enough c4 explosive and poison
gas to blow the whole chamber and kill
everybody in the belly I highly doubt
that baby doll has enough c4 and poison
to take down that entire building I
don't know mostly because I don't want
to Google how much c4 would it take to
take down a building thank God I'm glad
that's totally unnecessary action scene
filled with all the cliches happened
look how big this shit you want me to
stick this into my heart
are you nuts he doesn't starting to make
me feel like you don't need me at all I
need you to tell your teacher that you
need to get back on the boat and go
right now and your teacher will do just
that at the drop of a hat no questions
asked and the boat which is obviously on
no schedule whatsoever will just leave
immediately also I'd rather point our
deadly skin-eating chemical weapons at
you instead of holding you hostage
because I'm either incredibly evil or
incredibly stupid the rebel soldiers are
able to fly these two stolen Black Hawk
helicopters literally right past the US
Army Post at Yerba Buena Island without
raising any eyebrows it's an an emotion
trembler device custom made nobody knows
about it and nobody expects it dr. Cox
made this homemade motion sensor and
takes the time now to explain it because
he knows it's going to be important to
the plot later and then if they disturb
mr. back up here here's hoping that this
is where they decide to come in wasting
bullets captain fry captain Dara this is
my first operational situation with you
and your men and I have to say thus far
your conduct reflects your reputations
these guys just showed up in helicopters
two minutes ago what the kept they'd
done that's so special that you can
never again set foot on your native soil
Hummel explains all the potential
drawbacks to their treasonous plan which
they surely already know during the
middle of said treasonous plant I want
to know who I'm talking to this is
Brigadier General Francis X Hummel
United States Marine Corps from Alcatraz
out I'll cancel your reservations oh the
actual would she know that he needs to
cancel his reservations when Hummel
called his office did he tell the
secretary his fiendish plot before she
transferred the call to Womack it seems
Alcatraz was just reopened look says the
during a hostage criminal warfare
situation last night general Hummel
using brutal but non-lethal force under
the guise of a security exercise walked
up with 15 VX poison gas rockets did the
weapons depot think that was just a
security exercise if so it can failed
these pictures are part of the
standard-issue photo shoot that every
soldier who served in Vietnam had to
participate it and the Congressional
Medal of Jesus homo also fought in the
war on Christmas we never admitted we
sent troops into China
Sinclair uses the word admitted which
implies that he knows they sent troops
into China which leads me to believe
everyone else in this room and Hummel
would know about it
so why the bring it up we have to
identify the hostages and contact each
of their families uh tell him something
make up a story and we've got to keep
this undercover right because we
wouldn't want to evacuate the city or
anything also if we don't want this
getting out like all the hostages
families in light of them wouldn't it be
easier to not contact them at all 60 or
70 bless that's not so bad
thousand that dude actually thought of
the X gas missile would only cause sixty
or seventy people to die I mean I know
he's supposed to be the dumbass in this
movie but come on problem with VX poison
gas is that it's designed specifically
to withstand napalm I'm just gonna go
ahead and say everything they say about
VX gas and this movie is wrong I'm not
even gonna check the facts I'm pretty
sure all of it is wrong Nicolas Cage
having sex plus five sins
yeah downstairs in ten Goodspeed doesn't
ask any follow-up questions nor did the
person who called him have enough time
to even say we need you to come to San
Francisco
she still has on underwear which is a
sin for two reasons there is someone who
I think can help us wait a minute the
whole plot revolves around getting John
Patrick Mason to guide them through the
tunnels of Alcatraz
but Skye's been into solitary cell for
more than 30 years and Kyle Reese just
said Alcatraz has been ripped up and
rebuilt for years under there is amazing
she so how was Mason supposed to
navigate it even if he didn't know all
the tunnels so many years ago well you
know about VX gas discovered by mistake
in 1952 it was discovered by mistake in
1952 then why did what's-his-face tell
us it was designed was it accidentally
designed the FBI decided to set up their
mobile command at pier 39 which is a
giant tourist trap instead of the Coast
Guard port that is on a f--king island
off the Bay Bridge yes yes of course
FBI guys surely violates all sorts of
verticals by throwing any object that
this extremely dangerous and intelligent
prisoner watch go
no one pokes their head in and says I'm
sorry we can't allow them that be
lightweight aluminum chair is able to
scrape a quarter into a point and he
clearly didn't even need to do that with
the quarter at all given that the window
shattered only where his elbow hit it
and then just shattered the entire
fucking window don't come to San
Francisco like hell I'm not coming gee
forget her fiance is a chemical weapons
specialist for the FBI and is their own
work-related business if he's telling
her not to come she should probably
assume it's because something terrible
is happening
oh yes the nearby a shower phone classic
you've got to be kidding me no scissors
I mean did they tell Picasso no brush
this entire character these asshole FBI
guys didn't order room service but they
don't question all the expensive coming
up to the room at all try some of the
slot Nissen ordered snacks so room
service sent up all the lobster they
could find please shake on even the
Womack has a history with Mason he still
agrees to shake his hand when he
obviously looks like he's planning
something there's virtually no way this
action ends without John Spencer falling
to his death and probably dating Sean
Connery with him any other outcome is
simply you watch guys and run somewhere
after doing this but how is it anywhere
other than where these FBI agents are
coming from did they just let him run by
them at all I care about us are you
happy with you this character is the gay
equivalent of blackface watch see you
can't you get up for my arm how was it
not already pulled out Mason pushes
these guys out of the way on the up
escalator when there's a perfectly
stationary set of stairs who is right
Goodspeed does the same thing could
Mason not go around this broad of
placement and why was that asshole
driving so slow anyway yes that little
male car was delivering several
landmines not then this is just a bull
explosion I hope you're insured
oh why not because the car would most
likely fail and you probably died in
property damage and you're a chemist I
can think of several reasons old lady
cross industry you know EU moving broken
windshield not broken windshield
some serious bull some pure Ferrari it's
not mine either
good speed is supposed to be the good
guy right Jade mom Stacy Japan maybe he
wasn't talking to you Stacy
I got him why is the lab rat guy a
better field agent than all the actual
field agents the FBI clearly knows about
Jade's and she's listed in the computer
system as Mason's next of kin someone
else should have known to monitor Jade's
whereabouts because that seems like one
of the only places Mason would try to go
but I don't think that we should
romanticize what happened between you
and her meeting in a bar after Led
Zeppelin concert does she think that
because he's old he can't remember what
happened between him and her mother so
she has to lay it out for him or is this
just lazier backstory writing that this
movie seemed to excel at FBI ma'am
father's working with us he's helping us
resolve a dangerous situation good cover
Stanley let's hope Jay doesn't look
around at all the police officers with
their weapons drawn pointed at their
general direction
Michael imprint was in my head I was
underground for three days in the dark
you mean nobody went looking for you
down in these tunnels when you escaped
and that's when the blueprints were
accurate nobody looked for you for three
days in between the rock and a hard case
you've been in a combat situation
an incursion underwater to retake an
impregnable fortress held by an elite
team of US Marines in possession of 81
hostages and 15 guided rockets on the VX
poison gas
this guy doesn't define a combat
situation as much as he outlines the
plot of the movie so Goodspeed is
vomiting now that they're gonna bring
him along on this combat mission but so
far this is against the unlikely badass
character they've created commonly
sniffing a bomb lawyer well poisoned
melted soup crashing through a window in
a Ferrari I mean he's either a wimp or
he's not make up your mind I always
expected something like this was going
to happen nothing prepares you for
except for all that FBI training and
I'll send someone to pick up your
girlfriend and bring her here to the
command center instead of putting her
back on a plane to Virginia where she'll
be safe now this is after penis we come
in contact with a gas you have 20
seconds to inject it into your heart
first of all he's the Brainiac chemical
specialist he's supposed to be then he
would already know this
and of all atropine would probably work
great for real VX gas but wouldn't
douchey for this fantasy movie VX gas
that melts your skin instead of
explaining how atropine works to good
speed they should have used that
valuable time to explain something that
he doesn't know like how an oxygen tank
works night vision he meant to say
backlight
honestly this music is interchangeable
with the music from Crimson Tide I see
Alcatraz has one of those Galaxy Quest
contraptions you have to time correctly
to get past i memorize the timing this
is some serious unadulterated bull
welcome to the rock it's been said many
times in this movie but this is the
appropriate role quartets moment man-bun
motion sensors remember how earlier I
commented about it being serendipitous
that they decide to enter here well they
decided to enter at the location where
dr. Cox put his fancy motion sensor I
wanna use him there to cut the beam guy
explains what he's doing while he's
doing it even though there was no reason
to explain it out loud cliche which
wasn't a cliche until this movie did it
20 times before now and you tell your
men to safety their weapons drop them on
the deck the commander is real concern
is the safety of his men he should just
order them to put their guns down
because the way this is going they're
all about to get killed by the way what
happened to using the sleeping darts
they could have hit these guys and
locked them up since they were so strict
about keeping the body count low during
the VX gas heist I was trying to find a
reason to sin all this but I threw up
during this part so that's the sip call
me don't don't go this kid decides to
climb this ladder to a certain death
instead of staying behind and helping
Mason and Goodspeed complete this
mission Hummel doesn't raise the amount
by 10 million to pay for the families of
the Marines he just killed Hummel and
his men don't decide to check the
tunnels to see if there's anyone else I
didn't want this
I just wanted to threaten a major
American city with chemical warfare and
have the government pay me a ransom
without trying any funny business even
though I'm a decorated general and know
that they wouldn't just send a ransom
because that never happens he's dead yet
as I still flinch I need to know who the
fuck John Mason is right now sir 1962 J
Edgar Hoover is head of the FBI well
Matt gets real broad strokes with his
explanation because Paxton must not be
familiar with common knowledge American
history I got a lunatic out there man
with 15 missiles armed with some really
funky stuff you could have told my
daughter neither good speed nor any of
the other high-ranking military
officials tell Mason why they're on
Alcatraz until now even though they
could have used it as leverage to get
him to complete the mission before he
decided to leave instead of querying
them in the sewer and shooting them they
decide to drop a bomb because we haven't
had an explosion in a while they survive
this they outrun an explosion for a
while even though there
two feet of water yes in the amount of
time it takes mason to shoot the hvac
unit over this guy's head he can I had
to throw the grenade or roll out of the
way what's keeping them from taking that
whole thing with them manufactured plot
tension you say I accept your answer but
it still shit by the way where were all
these grenades a minute ago when they
were blowing away the seals in the
shower room Mike these could kind of
been handy I still vote the knockout
darts but if you're gonna kill people
also trained soldier throws the grenade
with way too much time left so that it
can be thrown back now that Mason have
enough time to get all the way up there
is there wormhole and Alcatraz that only
he knows about Alcatraz still has a
working PA system that can be accessed
from the outside for some reason good
speed is not the least bit suspicious of
this missile being inexplicably
unguarded ice lady instead of just
sniping him from afar they decide to
drop in and make their presence known
giving good speed time to defend himself
Wow seven hours blew by fast just six
minutes ago we were eight hours away
from the deadline and just now Mason is
trying to escape from his cell Goodspeed
cell has no furniture yet Mason's has a
bed with a mattress allowing him to make
a contraption that will help him escape
who could have predicted that Mason
would Han Solo back into the picture oh
that's right everyone all right back to
Stanley's girlfriend who continues to be
worthless in this story and I forgot
about 300 knots Ted a red one football
game hell no it's not going towards a
football game what time was it when good
speed and Mason got thrown into their
cells it was nighttime maybe early
morning seven hours went by which means
it should still be morning and there's
definitely no game being played this
early also though they said it was going
to Oakland right so why is it headed
toward Candlestick Park which is still
San Francisco this how the fuck do you
know that from Alcatraz you can hear
when a missile fails in Oakland you know
how this works
yeah that's a knife I think he has a
general idea of how that works the
United States Candyman flies at
half-mast whenever Michael Bay makes a
movie that speed decides to run around
with his extremely volatile nerve gas
when he's been on everyone's case this
entire film about being very very
careful when handling it all so why even
bother doing this at all the last
missile is already gone just call the
Pentagon and tell them to call off the
air strike and send a few guys with guns
to kill frog movie is going to make a
valiant attempt to tell me Stanley
catches up to this VX gas ball but I
still don't believe it good speeds
marble of VX gas survives this Stanley
chemistry nerd with no real FBI field
skills holds his own with a trained
soldier psychopath either he just stuck
himself in the heart through a
bulletproof vest or he wasn't wearing a
bulletproof vest
both of those things are terrible
options it's Grady at those wires on so
they could pull him out of the way
narrowly avoiding the blast explosions
of this size normally just send you
safely in the water so I don't know why
good speed was worried Mason put
America's biggest secrets inside a Pew
of a church leaving any number of
accidental discoveries or destructions
to occur is this what I think it is is
it a treasure map to find the
Declaration of Independence honey what I
really killed JFK Lee Harvey Oswald
right or do I want to open that can of
worms you've been chosen the island
awaits you
yessum
okay hit death threat to the face really
fucking hard
I'm eight I think there's something
wrong with you - yeah there's a dead guy
oh yeah
me today
in this particular cellblock Machine Gun
Kelly had what we call in the prison
system a bitch and one night in a
jealous rage Kelly took a makeshift
knife or Shiv and cut out for the
bitch's eyes Candyman Candyman Candyman
Candyman Candyman understand that
Terminator is out there
it can't be bargained with it can't be
reasoned with
it doesn't feel pity or remorse or fear
and it absolutely will not stop no I
just I said I want to find some Rockets
you tell me are you going to hospital
and more